ختام الناجح لمؤتمر المناخ من وجهه نظر
رئيسه وزير الخارجيه المصريه سامح شكري
الذي استجمع قواه بعد ساعات شاقه من
المفاوضات ليشيد بتحقق هدف ساعه اليه
الدول الناميه على مدار ثلاثه عقود وهو
انشاء صندوق لتمويل الخسائر والاضرار
الناجمه عن تغير المناخ
بعد 27 سنه من التناول من المطالبه من
الدول الافريقيه الدول الناميه ان يتحقق
ذلك فهو نجاح
للمؤتمر نجاح للاطراف ونجاح لمصر التي
تاسست هذا المؤتمر ولكن نائب رئيس
المفوضيه الاوروبيه
اعتبر ان الصديق الحقيقي هو من يخبرك بما
لا تود ان تسمعه فالقى بيان ختاميا ابرز
قلقا اكثر منه ارتياحا لنتائج المؤتمر
امام سواء للكوكب او للبشر فهو لا يضيف
الكثير على عاتق الدول الاكثر تلويثا
للمناخ لتسريع وزياده جهودهم لخفض
الانبعاثات وهو لا يوحي بثقه لناحيه
تمكننا من الوفاء بالالتزامات المدرجه في
اتفاقيه باريس او في كلاسكو العمل ماضي
تسود في اجواء شرم الشيخ الان جدليه نصف
الكوب الممتلئ ام الفارغ لناحيه النتائج
والتوصيات المنبثقه عن المؤتمر
لتنفيذ التعهد همم التاريخي لمئه مليار
همم الدول الناميه المتضرره حتى هذه
اللحظه اللي هو الهدف التكيف والتخفيف
ولكن نستطيع القول ان ده كان متوقع من قبل
ذلك انهم 20 اعلنت الدول انها لم تنفذ
بسبب الكرونه والنزالها سيتم تاجيله ل 20
23 وده هيكون ان شاء الله 28 شكري اعلن ان
الرئاسه المصريه بدات العمل من الان مع
الرئاسه الاماراتيه من اجل تسليمها اهتمام
الامور في قب توينتي 8 والذي قد يحمل امال
اكبر للدول التي تازت بالفعل من التغيرات
المناخيه تامر نصره العربيه القاهره